well today is the day to put caramel or
caramel depending on how you say it on
everything
including your popcorn that's right well
to celebrate a few national celebration
days this week rocky theaters hung out
with the popcorn girl herself to get an
inside look on how the sweden's savory
treat
is made right here in las vegas happy
national caramel day and tomorrow happy
national caramel popcorn day so i
figured
we come to a place that you can
celebrate both and that is popcorn girl
here in vegas
you are born and raised here yeah and
you are the popcorn queen
so let's start popping what's going on
here how does it work well first we're
uh our first step in making caramel crop
part
obviously is the pop popcorn it doesn't
just come all out without farming
right so here we go out of it you'll see
it it's starting to
it's starting to yeah it's starting to
uh come out here
whoa so you're used to making popcorn in
your microwave this is the real deal
yeah
so once it pops once it pours out here
then you mix it up here
oh my gosh right here it comes
i love it okay so this is step one step
one what is step two okay so step two
is pour the finished popcorn right in
here
and it's cooked it now for five minutes
and now it's gonna come out
after that oh my gosh have you ever seen
fresh caramel popcorn right out of the
what do you call that thing i don't want
to call it a problem it's a caramelizer
it's a caramelizer
and how long does that take how long
does the process taste
how long does that take from the time
you put start the cooking of the caramel
the whole process is an hour an hour
you guys this is a serious operation
here they're putting in some time and
some work
into your caramel popcorn so so now he's
gotta
separate it or it'll stick together okay
so you get those this very
popcorn was that i don't like yeah right
you want each little each little kernel
yeah
yeah okay i love it okay so let's talk
about the caramel itself because that's
what today is all about and what
tomorrow is all about what goes into the
perfect caramel recipe
well i know we have the ingredients over
here yes it's going to be
butter brown sugar some sugar and some
vanilla
okay okay this is you know
just you can't fail yeah yeah i know you
can't fill it with brown sugar and
butter
like vanilla right who does this because
this is unique to popcorn girl because
sometimes you just use the
something to use just powdered caramel
yes because this is what separates you
guys
that's right in fact when you buy these
cookers they come with
you know powdered caramel and you just
throw it right away ah
this that's not right i'm going to use
the real premium stuff here okay coming
up later
we're going to talk about the other
flavors that popcorn girl has to offer
because it is a long
unique menu which i love all right so
we'll stay tuned for that
oh my god my mouth is watery